>>THE WRESTLING WORLD WAS
ROCKED IN JULY WHEN WWE-ICON
HULK HOGAN WAS FIRED AFTER
MAKING NUMEROUS RACIST REMARKS.
HOWEVER AFTER WATCHING SOME OLD
FOOTAGE THAT INCLUDED A UGANDAN
GIANT, A SLAVE AND DONALD TRUMP
ENTERING THE WWE HALL OF
FAME I WANTED TO SIT DOWN WITH
SOME WRESTLERS AND
INVESTIGATE WHETHER OR NOT
WRESTLING HAS ALWAYS BEEN
RACIST.
>> TOMMY, YOU HAVE BEEN IN
WRESTLING FOR HOW MANY YEARS.
>> 25 YEARS.
>> WITH WRESTLING AND THE
CHARACTERS THAT ARE PLAYED, SOME
OF THESE CHARACTERS ARE FLAT OUT
RACIST.
>> YES.
>> YOU AGREE?
>> WHY IS IT OKAY IN WRESTLING
CUZ IT'S NOT REAL.
>> WHAT WAS THE MOST RACIST
THING YOU HAD EVER SEEN IN YOUR
CAREER AS A WRESTLER.
>> WELL, THERE HAVE BEEN N BOMBS
DROPPED ON TELEVISION.
>> KEEP IT UP [BLEEP].
>> IF YOU GO AND WATCH VIRGIL
FIGHT, THE KKK, THAT HAPPENS,
YOU CAN FIND IT ON YOUTUBE.
>> AND VIRGIL IS GOING AWAY.
THE BELL IS DOWN.
>> I CONDITION BELIEVE WHAT I'M
SEEING.
>> VIRGIL, YOU PLAYED A SLAVE,
YOU PLAYED A SLAVE.
>> IN THE '90S.
THEY JUST STARTED BEING NICE TO
BLACK PEOPLE THEN.
>> LISTEN, WE GOT PAID TO PLAY
CHARACTERS.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WON'T
DO FOR A DOLLAR?
>> A LOT OF THINGS I WON'T DO
FOR A DOLLAR.
>> NAME THEM.
>> THAT'S A DOLLAR.
HOW MANY THINGS WILL YOU DO FOR
$100,000.
>> WHAT, A-- GOT YOUR TONGUE.
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT A
DOLLAR, LET'S TALK ABOUT 100,000
DOLLARS.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT 100,000
DOLLARS IS.
>> I'M GLAD YOU DO, RICK.
>> IT'S RICKY.
>> OKAY, RICK.
>> USE THE Y.
>> SO YOU THINK RACISM HAS BEEN
TONED DOWN IN WRESTLING.
>> YES.
>> THEY HAD CELL PHONE CAMERAS
BACK IN THE DAY, I THINK WE ALL
WOULD HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FROM, I
MEAN I LIVED A ROCK 'N' ROLL
LIFESTYLE, YOU KNOW, AND HEY,
THERE'S SIX GIRLS, OKAY, ALL
SIX GIRLS, LET'S ALL GO HAVE
SEX.
THAT IS WHAT-- I HAD SEX GIRLS
AT ONCE.
>> COOL.
>> IF WE COULD JUST STEP BACK TO
THE RACISM REAL QUICK.
>> I [BLEEP] LOVE SEX
>> I'M GONNA TELL YOU RIGHT NOW,
VIRGIL, I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
RACISM IN WRESTLING.
>> IT'S THERE, I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
CAN YOU TEACH ME HOW TO BE THIS
RACIST?
>> RICKY, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
HOW TO BE
THE BIGGEST RACIST WRESTLER OF
ALL TIME.
>> IN ORDER TO BE A RACIST
WRESTLER YOU NEED A GIMMICK.
AND FOR SOME REASON VIRGIL
THOUGHT I WAS MEXICAN.
>> PUERTO RICAN, MEXICAN, BOTH
THE SAME.
>> THEY'RE NOT
>> YES, THEY ARE.
>> THEY ARE REALLY NOT.
>> SO HE GAVE ME MY OWN NAME.
THE BORDER JUMPER
>> I'M GOING TO BE A MEXICAN
RICKY VELEZ BORDER JUMPER EVEN
THOUGH I'M NOT MEXICAN BUT YOU
KEEP CALLING ME THAT, SO THAT IS
WHAT WE WILL DO.
HOW DO I BECOME THIS CHARACTER.
SHOW ME THE ROPES.
>> RIGHT IN THE FRONT ROW, RIGHT
IN A WOMAN'S FACE, MAKE LOVE TO
THAT WOMAN RIGHT THERE.
>> NOW I HAVE SINGLED OUT A
WOMAN TO SEXUALLY HARASS HER.
>> WHERE DO I GO FROM THERE?
>> YOU GRIND YOUR LITTLE ASS IN
HER, AND YOU JUMP AND YOU GREET
THE PEOPLE.
>> I'M THE BORDER JUMPER, YOU
DON'T LIKE IT.
[BLEEP] YOU.
>> DON'T KICK ME.
>> [BLEEP].
>> WHAT AM I SAYING? HELP ME
OUT HERE.
>> I'LL TAKE YOUR WOMEN.
I'LL TAKE YOUR MONEY.
>> YOU WILL TAKE YOUR JOBS.
>> CUZ PEOPLE THINK MEXICANS
TAKE THEIR JOBS.
BUT WHAT JOB DID YOU REALLY HAVE
THAT THEY TOOK?
>> STOP IT RIGHT HERE.
>> BOOM, DROP ONE KNEE.
AND YOU BITE.
I'M GONNA ROLL IN LIKE A BIG
BLACK BURRITO AND JUST MUNCH ON
ME LIKE I GOT SALSA ON ME.
>> ONCE AGAIN I'M PUERTO RICAN.
>> ALL THE WAY AROUND.
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
>> VIRGIL, THIS IS NOT WORKING.
>> IT WILL WORK.
>> COME ON.
>> COME ON, COME ON.
>> WHY DO YOU HAVE SO MUCH
CHANGE ON YOU, VIRGIL?
>> YOU FOUGHT LIKE A CHICKEN.
FIGHT, FIGHT.
>>OUT.
>> HE'S GOT RABIES.
>> WITH MY TRAINING NOW
COMPLETE, I'M READY TO BECOME
THE MOST RACIST WRESTLER IN
HISTORY.
>> THE BORDER JUMPER.
>> BUT WILL I SURVIVE MY REAL
WRESTLING MATCH WITH THIS FORMER
FAKE SLAVE?
FIND OUT NEXT TIME
>> VIRGIL, YOU WANT TO
WRESTLE ME, FOR THE MINORITY
BELT?
YOU CANNOT FIGHT ME.
ARE YOU NOT GOOD AS BORDER
JUMPER.
ARE YOU GARBAGE, VIRGIL,
GARBAGE.
>> GET AWAY FROM MY TABLE.
>> VIRGIL IS NOT THE MOST
IMPRESSED.
I AM.
>> I'M GOING TO KICK YOUR--
>> Larry: THANKS, RICKY.